SPEAKER: Are you ingesting large
amount of data for analysis
or looking to simplify
the development
of event-driven applications?
Then stay tuned to learn
more about Cloud Pub/Sub.
In the last episode, we looked
at Cat-Out's asynchronous order
processing service with
and without Cloud pub/sub.
We also learned
how Cloud Pub/Sub
is perfect for such use
cases to scale seamlessly
for millions of messages.
Today, we will consider
our Cat-Out example again,
which is a simple
case of a workflow
application implemented as
a set of services connected
asynchronously by messages.
We will also see how Cloud
Pub/Sub helps Cat-Out expand
their application globally.
As the name Pub/Sub
indicates, Cloud Pub/Sub
supports a publisher
subscriber model.
A publisher application
creates and sends messages
to a topic which is
a named resource.
And the messages are
stored until acknowledged
by all subscribers.
To receive these messages,
a subscriber application
creates a subscription
to a topic.
The subscriber
receives a message
by either Cloud
Pub/Sub pushing them
to the subscribers
chosen endpoint
or by subscriber pulling
them from the service.
When the message is
acknowledged by the subscriber,
it is removed from the
subscription backlog
and not delivered again.
The message itself can contain
the payload and optional
attributes that describe
the payload content.
Communication can be
one too many also called
fan out, many to one or
fan in, and many to many,
which means if subscriber
x wants to receive messages
from two different
publishers, a and b,
it can be achieved by creating
two subscriptions corresponding
to the topics for
each publisher, which
is a many-to-one model.
Similarly, if two
different applications
want to subscribe to the same
message from a publisher,
then it can be
achieved by creating
two different subscriptions
from the same topic, which
is a one-to-many model.
Now, remember Cat-Out, the order
processing and delivery service
from the last episode?
Let's see how Pub/Sub
topic and subscriptions
would be set up for this
asynchronous functionality.
The order service sends the
messages to Pub/Sub topic
where they get stored.
The packaging and
notification service
subscribe to these messages
through the respective Pub/Sub
subscription in
a fanout fashion,
Packaging service will send
messages to Pub/Sub topic.
And the shipping and
notification service
will subscribe to the
respective Pub/Sub subscription.
Similarly, the shipping
service will send the messages
to Pub/Sub topic.
And the order and
notification service
will subscribe to their
respective Pub/Sub
subscriptions.
Now, Cat-Out is going
to a global expansion
with packaging service in
Europe and order processing
service in US.
Because Cloud Pub/Sub
is a global service,
it ensures that messages
get from one location
to another no matter
where these services are
with consistent latency and
no replication necessary.
This is huge for
the Cat-Out team,
because they can focus
on developing the service
and leave the global
scaling to Cloud Pub/Sub.
What do we need to know about
publisher and subscriber
endpoints?
Well, let's see.
Publishers can be
any application
that can make https
request to Google APIs.com.
An App Engine app, a web service
hosted on Google Compute Engine
or any other third-party
network and install an app
for desktop or mobile
devices or even a browser.
Pull subscribers can
also be any application
that can make https
requests to Google APIs.com,
although Push subscribers must
be web hook end points that
can accept Post
requests over https.
Cloud Pub/Sub is all
about service integration.
Data is ingested
into Cloud Pub/Sub
from the front-end services
databases and other event
producers, then received
by Cloud Dataflow
or our other event
processing service
for de-duplication,
ordering, and enrichment.
From Cloud Dataflow,
the event can
be sent to multiple targets.
It can be used to facilitate
end user experiences,
like managing notification
via Firebase notifications
and messaging, or storing
end user state in Firestore
or managing an IT device.
Other targets could be data
warehouse or data lakes,
like BigQuery and GCS or
event-driven and [? sololess ?]
apps, like Cloud Functions,
App Engine, and Cloud Run.
Bigtable could
also be your target
for operational
databases or just caches.
Cloud Pub/Sub has
lots of different use
cases, which can be categorized
into two broad buckets.
It's great for streaming
analytics or ingestion of data
into analytical systems.
It's also great for implementing
asynchronous workflows,
like the order
processing application
we saw earlier in
the Cat-Out example.
Let us know how you're use Cloud
Pub/Sub in your environments
in the comments below.
All right.
So today, we learned what is
Cloud Pub/Sub, how it works,
and some of the most
common use cases.
Join us next to dive deeper and
actually build a Cloud Pub/Sub
system from scratch.
If you liked this
video and would
like to see more
such content, don't
forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.